sunshine while most scientists agree
that we have a few billion years left
before our sun dies the plot of 2007's
sunshine moves that timeline up
considerably it's 2057 and the sun is
already nearly dead
the earth endures freezing temperatures
worldwide and a small crew led by a
physicist played by cillian murphy is
sent on a hail mary mission to save the
earth they must attempt to reignite the
sun with a nuclear bomb the size of
manhattan
28 days later director danny boyle pulls
inspiration from films such as 2001 a
space odyssey and alien to take viewers
on a wild psychological ride from start
to finish
moon 2009's moon is a deliciously spare
sci-fi film that uses its modest budget
to great effect the film focuses on a
solitary astronaut played by sam
rockwell who is manning a lunar mining
operation
moon explores both ethical and
existential questions when the astronaut
begins hallucinating about a young woman
his only companion on the base is an
artificial intelligence program voiced
by kevin spacey
what about the messages she sent to me
sam i can only account for what occurs
on the base
when sam discovers what appears to be
his doppelganger in another area of his
base
things start to get pretty crazy what's
real and what isn't another earth
if you like philosophical conundrums and
a dose of existentialism with your
sci-fi
then 2011's another earth is for you a
planet identical to earth in every way
has just been discovered hiding in our
solar system
and there's speculation that the
planet's inhabitants are identical as
well
meanwhile a young scientist played by
brit marlene has her career cut short
when she accidentally kills several
people while driving drunk
ethical dilemmas arise for the young
woman when she meets the survivor from
the car crash falls in love with him and
is later offered a chance to travel to
this earth too the mystery flight member
is 21 year old rhoda williams who is
rumored to be an
ex-convict did her doppelganger cause a
similar crash on that planet
are her victims alive there another
earth explores all these questions and
more making for an entertaining sci-fi
movie that'll leave you thinking deep
thoughts long after the credits roll
coherence shot on a shoestring budget
with no script and no special effects
2013's coherence also stars director
james burkett's friends and was shot
primarily
in his own home the movie follows a
group at a dinner party which is
interrupted by the flyover of a comet
the effects of the comet temporarily
open up pathways to parallel realities
inhabited by the same group of friends
the group eventually fractures breaking
off to explore the other realities and
chaos ensues
this whole night we've been worrying
there's some dark version of us out
there somewhere
what if we're the dark version by
choosing friends who were also skilled
improvisational actors and who didn't
know each other before filming started
burkitt harnessed their own creativity
to create a thought-provoking and
thrilling film that is also almost
entirely improvised
pre-destination as far as science
fiction plots go
2014's pre-destination doesn't start out
on the most original note
ethan hawk plays an operative from a
time-traveling intelligence agency back
on the job after a horrible injury with
one last mission to complete
he has to prevent a time-traveling
terrorist from setting off a bomb in new
york city in 1975.
this might sound like the beginning of a
fairly formulaic sci-fi action film but
predestination is anything but when
hawk's character meets a stranger with a
darkly compelling life story he takes
the stranger along on his mission and
things get pretty weird from there with
a wild ending most viewers will never
see coming
snow piercer the limitless hubris of
humanity is a common theme of science
fiction films and 2013 snowpiercer is an
eye-popping example of the form
humans have essentially destroyed the
planet by fiddling with earth's climate
bringing on a new ice age
humanity's last remaining survivors are
all aboard the snow piercer a massively
long train constantly circumnavigating
the globe on a continuous track
20 years after the climate disaster a
distinct caste system has emerged on the
train
one of the lower class citizens played
by captain america's chris evans leads a
rebellion to the front of the train to
try to take control of the locomotive by
force
the group faces many foes along the way
including the incomparable tilda swinton
as the bizarre minister mason
i am a hat you want a shoe i belong on
the head
you belong on the foot thanks for
watching click the looper icon to
subscribe to our youtube channel plus
check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love too